levy sinois sont désormais prévenus la
ryder cup la coupe du monde du golf
arrive le 28 septembre 2018 sur les
greens du golf national de saint quentin
en yvelines pour sensibiliser le public
à cette manifestation la ville a décidé
d'inaugurer ce samedi 9 septembre un
compte à rebours géant centre sportif
les pyramides
c'est aux portes voisins et que
j'aimerai que lévis sinois je dirais
profitent de cet événement soit
conscience de la de l'envergure de
l'événement de ce que ça peut apporter à
notre territoire
donc c'est vrai que on a souhaité qu'on
allait les associés en ce jour de forums
et puis que ce soit dans le gymnase qui
qui voit passer presque 200 mille
personnes par an la ryder cup est le
troisième plus grand événement sportif
planétaire plus de 700 millions de
personnes devraient regarder la
compétition devant leur écran de
télévision
à saint quentin en yvelines près de 70
mille supporters seront présents
quotidiennement pendant les trois jours
de compétition
une première historique pour un golf en
france c'est la plus grande compétition
de golf au monde les meilleurs joueurs
américains contre les meilleurs joueurs
européens dont je pense que simplement
c'est au niveau sportif c'est quelque
chose de très important mais il faut que
toute la population saint-quentinoise
puissent en profiter
à l'heure où ce reportage est diffusé lé
reste exactement 3 180 jours avant le
début de la compétition